I'll go on and welcome to another
google+ hangout I'm super excited to be
here today I'm coming to you live from
Hollywood California and we're talking
about how to manage your time
effectively and I've got a special guest
with me Tom Tate who is at a weber which
is the email software that I use the
project manager there and is mr. time at
the business tomm welcome aboard yeah
really shy here is gonna be awesome
welcome you're gonna have to uh got it
there okay look at how people quickly a
little bit what could you one sec again
oh yeah let me just close out the other
window I'm get a little black okay your
photographer yeah just a quick intro to
the audience about what you do yeah your
problem so again my name is Tom Tate i'm
the project managers of marking team
here at a lever and we have a closer a
15-person team and we have obviously a
lot of marketing initiatives going on so
my job really is to help coordinate our
efforts make sure that our team is being
as productive as possible make sure that
we're communicating as effectively as
possible and make sure that everything
is going as smoothly as possible it's a
lot of fun working with such an awesome
team um and really it all comes down to
you managing your time you know it's
something that I've been kind of a
pseudonym for really long time so I've
been doing project management on various
levels with various team sizes for about
six years so I've worked with a lot of
different time management project
management methodologies so that's kind
of like my background excited cool very
cool so we're talking about time
management today and has entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs are you know the hardest
working people I think on the planet
that the 40-hour workweek doesn't exist
for most entrepreneurs and so it's
always one of the biggest challenges is
how do I manage my time effectively and
get stuff done when I'm doing everything
from being the janitor to being the CEO
of my business and so there's a bunch of
questions coming in already but I wanted
to
ask you what your favorite you know
number one tip is that you use to help
you manage your day absolutely um so
real quick I have this one more I'm
going to try to use it effectively I'm
standing out on my hollow a lot a little
energy today so I don't distract you own
that but over here I've been wrong for
real quick these Seven Pillars of you
know the seven most important things
that I kind of look for to maximize to
make sure that our media's product as
possible and i'm going to pick out one
of them and that's going to answer your
question self um focus and purpose on
madura an effective Calendar apps lists
Coruscant priories routines and health
and I'm going to try to touch on a
little bit of each of these today but if
I don't get any of them no obviously
they're pretty self-explanatory but you
know the most important one is probably
going to be Pomodoro right so the answer
your question what is my favorite I
management technique it's something
called Pomodoro that you can google it
and after this I'm going to put a couple
links on the YouTube page of resources
that you guys can check out but real
quick I maduro in a nutshell so is p 0
end of vor oh and actually need that for
a tomato tomato timer so it's a 25
minute timer that you stood on that's
pretty popular in cooked right so
basically what you want to do is we want
to set a timer for 25 minutes and to
learn that 25 minutes you want to pick a
few priorities offer your to do list do
important things that you need to do and
you just want to focus on those things
so when I'm in working for that 25
minute block I'm not checking my email I
I closeouts where I you know no facebook
put myself inside you know in short of
like emergencies I've really tried to
remove all distractions and focus on the
priorities and what happens is you'll
hear this a lot and you know
entrepreneurs like to say this a lot
they get in the zone to be like
the only way to get in the zone is to
remove those distractions right so I
said the 25 minute timer I get in the
zone and I work as as diligently and as
hard as I possibly can get my ex used
done right and then after that 25
minutes each other whether I got done or
not I take a hard stop right 25 minutes
the timer goes off and I pick a five
minute break and the five minute break
is really important mentally and
physically right so I'll take a
five-minute break um I'll stand up I
work at a stand up a standing desk you
know I've in a city desk use alternate
foot above sitting I like to stand up
and get the blood flowing um and that's
when i'll check my email right so i
think five minutes where it's like okay
let me check my email let me see what's
going on twitter let me see if I getting
text messages you know like all those
things that like distract you door your
of your work bed i crammed into this
little five minute free and hopefully
there's no typically there's never
anything super important that makes you
to drop everything you need to do it
sometimes they're afraid and that's an
opportunity to say okay I got email
after respond to it um but normally it's
just quick review and then I operate
vacuum to another 25 minutes Pomodoro so
all kind of staff some of these throw on
it and after you do a couple I'll spend
the five minute break to something more
substantial like either 15 their break
or take a break from launch receptor
than that that's my favorite technique I
would be talking a little bit about that
you know throughout this but I'm curious
to know what you're with your favorite
you know time Adam technique it I love
it I'm gonna head inside because it's
like some garbage truck or something
happening that's causing some noise out
here so happens when you live stream all
on vacation um for me kind of similar
it's chunking my day and what I find is
chunking days of the week to do
different things so on monday i do all
my admin stuff kind of setup for the
week to uh you know on my own i'm not
having to deal with any distractions i
have to deal with anybody or any issues
and I just get work done for the week on
Tuesday right in the book so i'm
spending the day writing on wednesday do
my video so i'll spend time making I
mean 21 videos a week on my youtube
channel so that's like onesies down put
insane just sit down and do those and
then Thursday is my public facing day so
doing this like it's a thursday today
right so doing interviews doing meetings
taking coffees having phone calls with
people i do that on thursdays and so I
find having different days where I do
different assignments or different types
of work I find that really helps me um
because for example it I pointed out
maybe a slick personality where there
are days where I just wanna I just want
to work and get my stuff done and like I
don't have to mop the shape if I don't
want to shave I see you don't shave but
you know you gotta you gotta trim that
beard on something I shave every day for
my morning routine so I wake up in the
morning and I shave that's the first
thing i do everyday and then for
whatever reason you know by like
temporary letter topic it just comes
back right so like it's very difficult
thank you you're like the Wolverine yeah
I like Wolverine it just comes back I
can tell that's amazing um yeah and then
just like this I find that there's a lot
of switching costs they're switching
time where if I'm in the meeting with
somebody and then and then I have to
switch focus and then start writing my
book yeah I find that it's just what
extra gear it's really hard for me to do
and if somebody interrupts me while I'm
writing my book then to get back into
where I was is there just insane it's
too much work and I can't I can't do it
like it's just just a big productivity
killer so I like the chunking method I
use it more for chunking days than
chunking time on days but that's cool I
like it I like it and you know I'm gonna
probably i'm gonna throw out a big
disclaimer like everything that I say
today is like actionable strategies that
try to be more profit but it really
productivity is all about
experimentation can be very personal to
what you do and how you do it
and what your life situations like when
your schedule fly itself like I've got
my rhythm through experimenting and I'm
always in a constant state more
experimentation to try to optimize it so
it's all about you know not staying so
firm and one thing but you know just
really trying to find what works and
then when you find it just continue to
work at it and make it a routine and
make it better um but yeah I totally
agree with what you're saying that's
kind of like you know my first beer in
your focus and purpose like we each
chunk out of your full days like that at
least you have that focus you know like
you know like this is what I days
objective part I think that's you know
what are you doing is 25 minutes were
you doing in the 24 hour block just
making sure that you have your living
with focus and purpose i think it is
these keys yeah oh it's totally cool
well there's a bunch of questions coming
in and fizzes you watching live if you
want to question the chat well we'll try
to get to them as a lot coming in the
first one Kevin is writing what's the
best way to plan my day what do you
think tom okay so for me the best way to
answer that question is not on that day
right so I think the best way to plan
your day is to do it the day before or
even earlier if you can't write because
as soon as you start planning your day
on a day off um you're opening yourself
up to distractions you're opening
yourself up to possibly bullion items
that are top priority um and your open
opening yourself up to really getting
stuck in a rut at 6am or 7 or 8 a.m.
when you sit down and plan your day
right because there's nothing worse than
looking at a hundred two dudes right and
that's kind of the entrepreneurs life
right because like you said you're doing
everything there's nothing worse than
point out your cute list the morning out
I'm saying what am I going to work on
that right so i definitely recommend
doing that you know either the day
before the night before you know
reserving a little bit of time to saying
what am I going to work on
more because that was when you wake up
and you go to start your day your
morning routine or whatever you
typically do you're not creating your
to-do list your consulting your to-do
list right so I think that that's really
important to start the day before um and
I would also recommend of taking your so
like I'm assuming that a lot of people
have a [ __ ] mute right um I always
recommend optimizing your commute to to
mentally prep yourself for your most
important tasks right so that you know
if you're typically taking the train or
driving and you're not optimizing that
time then you get to the office and then
you have to get into work though right
so like if you can take some of that
time it's about the all of it to you
mentally prep yourself would you want to
accomplish that day I find that that's a
really great time to do it yeah I love
that uh I mean I totally agree you
almost took the words out of my mouth on
that the thing I'm add in terms of
getting mentally prepared is uh having a
morning routine that supports you and
sets you up for success every day where
I find a lot of entrepreneurs uh it's
tough because we don't have a boss right
we don't have somebody who's silly
counting on us every day to show up at a
certain time and so you're the only one
hold yourself accountable and that's
that's hard uh and so I find it's easy
to yes you need to have the plan for the
day you need to like figure that out the
day before the week before so you don't
just wander aimlessly yeah I flip side I
find a lot of entrepreneurs will have a
plan but then they don't stick to the
plan you know maybe they wake up late
they miss their first thing and and so
having a morning routine that sets you
up for success uh will help so whatever
that whatever that means to you so you
know I'll start the day with a quick
note of what I'm grateful for and then
I'll send a quick message my wife is
usually out before I am in the morning
and then I look at my youtube comments
that gets me excited because always some
you know fun positive feedback
things that make me you know want to do
this and get excited and to like having
a morning routine that sets you up
whatever it is for you that gets you
ready for the day I think is also super
important to help you stick to your plan
you create the plan then you gotta stick
to the plan yeah I totally agree with
the morning routine and you know one
thing that i would recommend that i
recently did this may be a box or a half
of us I've always woke up at six a.m.
and then one day I decided you know what
I'm going to try to wake up at 5am and
you would be shocked at how productive
you can be in the morning we just add
one hour right so like in terms of being
tired you know like yeah there's an
adjustment period for a little bit
waking up an hour earlier but I'm
telling you my wife's asleep I started
to sleep I can get so much done I get
bored on in that hour that I could get
down at home or right so like just send
the content it is awesome I've
definitely recommend any entrepreneur
did you struggling to get that morning
routine down just try to set your clock
back just a little bit and just see if
the magic happens because like it was a
little eerie game changer wow that that
I'm a salsa dancer that'd be hard for me
man I have a lot of late nights what
time are you going to bed at night wake
up at five in the morning so again you
know my find positive this one right
here which is health right so I i
recently got a i recently got 50 which
is cool so i crack my ski um so I'm
trying to get like at least six and a
half hours of sleep a night right so I I
typically try to be in bed by 10 um you
know and i'll read and stuff but like i
try to get the dead you know relatively
you know my tummy is i'm not a salsa
dancer and you know um you know 10 to 11
it's pretty good for me and then you
know my are certified and another day
two years i try not to sneeze that's a
bunch of snoozing office it's over but
ma my wife is in the room with me and as
you said go to sleep at 10am she looked
at me and started nodding so i think now
she's we're going to try to do that
right because so much tours like you get
in the zone at this weight nights you
know like this but any our like the 925
it works for me but again like I said
earlier all the odd experimentations to
like if you find that like your creative
juices are on it one o'clock in the
morning and you have the luxury of your
business to sleep in and still get that
six and a half seven hours of sleep
let's sleep in and you know your
business doesn't suffer for it by all
means you know like find the rhythm
that's going to work for sure yeah I
love that and I think that's really key
is the experimentation I know you've
brought it up a couple times now and I'm
a huge fan I'm constantly tweaking I
know you are too there is no like
perfect solution yeah it's a perfect
solution for right now and you're always
trying to find ways to be better and as
you change and as your interest change
and as your projects change and as your
lifestyle changes then you need to
change your schedule and your techniques
with it so I'm hope some ideas that for
you guys watching you can use to try out
the experiments in your life to UM the
next question was how do i get rid of
distractions okay that's a fantastic
question and i'm gonna say something
that might have said my fellow team
members here okay i get rid of
distractions sometimes not all the time
but I work in an office with a team and
like I said I didn't I try to do this
this Pomodoro this 25-minute time block
um so I have a trip and I'm gonna share
with people and I had a PT members call
me out on this and now they're all going
to call me out on it but I gotta head
come on and I don't play any music so I
will sit at my desk and work diligently
with my headphones on people walk by me
thinking that I mean do not disturb the
headphones on music's playing but in all
honesty in Austria there's nothing
playing and that really helps me it
really helps me like zone it right like
I just I'm able to turn off and not
register
goodbye all the different things going
on around me and I don't do this all day
because I like to be accessible right
like you know I work on a team I want to
be communicating well affect the book so
this isn't an all day thing but when you
know you have that form stuff to get
done I put my headphones on and I just
focused um close out my email close out
my chat client close out there is
distracting tabs um there's a really
great application it's a web app it's
called rescue time and rescue time lets
you track what you do on the way um so
if you know it basically shows you it
will give you a report on where your
flavors spending your time which is
pretty awesome so if you're spending all
your time on Facebook or Twitter it's
going to show you that right you can
tweak your schedule based on that I
think I lost you i'm looking at a frozen
screen so let me see if I tweet this
you
you
you
hey can you see me guys
sorry everyone I lost Evan but I'm in
the google hangout and I'm trying to see
if he's available and will keep things
rolling
okay I'm gonna wait patiently I'm going
to wait patiently for every of that but
I was just told by my team that you can
see me so if you can see me I'm just
going to keep talking and we'll wait for
Evan and hopefully he can walk back here
maybe its connectivity issues okay I'm
going to keep going down my list sorry
to talked about Pomodoro and we don't
i'll wait for Evan for the questions but
I'm just going to give you action items
that you guys can take right away and
start using um running down this list
right so calendar here's a little trick
that I used for my counselor at a weber
we can schedule each other's time right
like we can book each other to be in
meetings and there's nothing more
zapping to your productivity than being
in a meeting that either a you don't you
don't have to be in um or being you
don't want to be in or see you know and
media management is a whole other topic
but if the meeting doesn't have a good
agenda or actually might us to leave you
know was at the meeting it's going to be
a total total factor productivity so
here's another trick just like the
headphone trick um I schedule my own
meetings we're all block off the
stretching of my day um where it looks
like I'm busy but I'm not really busy I
don't have a specific meeting and I like
to reserve chunks of time for getting
the important stuff done um because if
you leave your calendar wide open and
you don't schedule time for yourself
people are just going to nap that time
so it's important with whatever calendar
haven't used whether it's Google
Calendar whether it's you know the the
iOS calendar always you know schedule
block some time for yourself where it
doesn't just have to stay busy it could
say you know this is the day and time
where I'm going to pay all my bills and
that's that kind of stuff is really
important right so for me it's it's the
big priorities or always am here for my
head but they're just as as weighty as
one
little priorities so if you have 100
little tasks oh and you don't schedule
time in your calendar to knock out all
those little tasks every time you sit
down to work on a big task you're going
to be stuck thinking in the back of your
head well I gotta pay this bill and I
have to mail out that letter and I have
to respond to that one insignificant
emails you're always going to have these
little test so schedule time in your
calendar for yourself don't let other
people steal that time and really focus
um next I'm going to talk about apps
right so I have a couple apps that I'm
going to rattle off and i will send some
I'll put some links in the goo or
hangout apps that you guys can check out
on your own time the first one and this
is probably the one app that I
absolutely cannot live without it is an
app called simple note i'm pretty sure
it's from the creators of wordpress or
somehow their associated with the team
at automatic and ghost wordpress um
simple note is the okay I'm going to
blow your minds simple note is an
application where you can simply take
those and it's the interface is so clean
and the only reason why i use it is
because i have an android cell phone I I
have an iPad at on there i use heavily I